Hello, I'm Dr. Brooke
Schaud-Laurent.
I'm an osteopathic family
medicine physician.
I'm an associate
professor
and chair for
the Department
of Clinical Medicine
at NYIT College
of Osteopathic
Medicine at Arkansas
State University.
I also serve as
the executive
director for the
Delta Population
Health Institute
at NYIT-COM,
the community engagement
arm for the
medical school.
Today, my presentation
will be on health
disparities, Closing
the Gap Through Cultural
Competencies. This is
one of two parts. In
the first part of this
presentation, we'll
be defining what are
health disparities,
explain the contributing
factors of health
disparities,
explain how social
determinants of
health affect
health outcomes, and
explain how
practices in health
care contribute to
health outcomes.
There are many
expectations that will be
expected of you as
rising osteopathic
physicians, and this is
one of them, that you
will have a lifelong
commitment to grow
in the discipline of
cultural competency,
to provide quality
health care to
all persons, and
to lead communities
holistically
and with equity.
this is our definition
of health disparities
it's it's the difference
in the incidence
prevalence mortality
and burden of disease
as well as other adverse
health conditions
or outcomes that
exist among specific
populations well documented
in subpopulations
based on socioeconomic
status, education,
age, race,
ethnicity, geography,
disability, gender, and
or ****** orientation.
Because of the limitation
of time, we won't
be able to get into
the disparities of all
the populations and
demographics. We will
however touch on the
most prevalent ones and
provide references at
the end of this lecture
to learn more about
how other populations
are experiencing health
in the United States.
One of the disparities
that have been
well documented is
life expectancy.
This graph is from
the county health
rankings and shows
health disparities
specifically in life
expectancy among
race and ethnic
groups. The population
with the highest
life expectancy
between 2010 and
2020 is in the Asian
Pacific Islander
population, followed by
the Hispanic
population, then white.
American Indian
and Alaskan Native
follows and then the
Black population.
Please note, excuse
me, that this does not
take into account the
change in life expectancies
after the pandemic.
There are recent
studies that have shown
that the gaps have
widened for minority
populations. You can see
here that the differences
of life expectancy
ranges between 10 to
20 years, depending on
which people group an
individual is part of.
Another disparity
is unfortunately
found in maternal
and child health.
In this diagram in
the upper left side,
it notes that of all
the preterm births
in 2020, 14.4% were in
the Black population
followed by native
hawaiian pacific
islanders american indian
and alaskan natives
where you have preterm
births children
that were born in
preterm have significant
chronic illnesses
as a sequelae
of preterm birth
a higher risk
of having
chronic illnesses
as a sequelae for
preterm births in the
upper right corner
we're looking at
babies born of low
birth rate in 2020.
And in this period,
it was captured that
14.2% of babies
born of low birth
rate were of the black
population followed
by native American
Pacific Islanders
and then American
Indian Alaskan Natives.
For pregnancy
related mortality in
the lower left corner
per 100 births,
40.8 deaths
per 100 births
occurred in the
black population.
The next highly
affected group was the
American Indian, native
Alaskan group by 29
.7 per 100 births.
Then followed by the
Asian population, 12
.7 per 100,000 births.
When you move over to
the right lower corner,
where there's a
measurement of infant
mortality per 1,000
live births in 2018,
again, we see that within
the black population
there's a higher rate
10.8 per 1000 live
births followed by 9
.4 per 1000 births uh
in the native hawaiian
specific pacific
islander group and
then followed by 8.2 in
american indian alaskan
natives so again these
are these graphs
show some staggering
disparities um among
different ethnic and racial
groups and it's important
to note not only
that they are there
but as osteopathic
physicians to understand
why these disparities
exist and we'll be
getting into that a little
bit later on another
intersection not only
lies within race and
ethnicity but also
where you live contributes
significantly to
your health outcomes
this was an article in
rural counties with
majority in health affairs
excuse me that had an
article that showed
rural counties with
majority black or
indigenous populations
suffer the highest rates
of ********* death.
There's a CDC study
done in 2017 that noted
the same. It's important
to note that when
we're looking at these
different populations,
when you have these
different demographics
and they're compounded,
it puts populations
at significant risk
for health outcomes
that are deadly. This
is a map from county
health rankings that
breaks down the geography
of counties across
the United States.
The areas here that
in purple are shown
and have demonstrated
to be the least
healthiest counties. The
area that you see
highlighted here is in
the Mississippi Delta.
This is the region
where the Arkansas
campus is based. And as
you can see, along
with areas in Alaska,
rural areas here
in the southwest,
areas of Appalachia
here and here, Um,
but there are
these significant
disparities and, uh,
these counties are
encountering
significant challenges.
And this map
again shows that
where you live
does matter.
There have been many
studies to show,
um, along a Metro
line, for example, um,
this This is a map
of New York City
that shows the
Metro lines 456 and
line NQR, and
depending what stop
you get off of,
it actually does
determine what your
life expectancy is.
It could be a difference
of close to 10 years.
Here around Lincoln
Center, it's
around 84 years.
If you go to where
the Apollo Theater
is, it's 76.
If you look at
Queens and Astoria,
82 years.
So there are a lot
of studies that
are looking at what
are the environmental
factors that are
causing these
discrepancies and
disparities for
life expectancies
in the same state.
the map that you see
on the right here shows
a similar example
this is a highway in
california where depending
what exit that you
get off of your life
expectancy could be 81
and going further up
north near fresno we
could be 75 so as we're
looking at these studies
we should be looking
and asking what is
going on in these
areas that we have such
significant disparities
in life expectancies.
What I'm making reference
to here in terms
of environmental
factors are what is
known as the social
determinants of health.
The social determinants
of health are
defined are the conditions
in the environments
where people are
born, where they live,
learn, work, play,
worship, and age that
affect a wide range
of health functioning
and quality of life
outcomes and risks.
The six broad
categories or buckets of
social determinants of
health are as follows,
And you'll see some
variation of these
in different
organizations, but they
pretty much fall in
these broad categories.
One is economic
stability, and that is
defined by employment,
income, expenses,
debt, medical bills,
and the support
that they have.
The next category
is neighborhood
and physical
environment, housing,
transportation,
safety,
parks, playgrounds,
walkability, your zip
code. All these things
contribute to the
health outcomes of an
individual or family.
Next is education,
your literacy level,
language, early
childhood education,
vocational training,
the ability to obtain
higher education is
one determinant of
health. And the next
one is food security,
hunger, access to
healthy options.
The next category is
community and social
context, such as
social integration,
a unit in a family
or communities
that have strong
support systems,
a community that
where there's true,
thoughtful community
engagement.
areas where there are
discrimination and
stress can act and
be a significant
determinant of health
and the sixth bucket is
health care system
health care coverage
provide availability
provider linguistic
and cultural competency
and quality of
care for the most
part you as a rising
osteopathic physician
will have the most
authority and influence
in this last column.
And for the most
part, for the rest of
your education, it will
be focusing on your
competencies as a
healthcare professional
in providing care
that is culturally
appropriate and providing
quality of care.
But it's important
to be aware that
these other
columns here are
significant drivers
in health outcomes,
more so than health
care systems.
Health outcomes
are defined as
mortality, morbidity,
life expectancy,
health care expenditures,
health status, and
functional limitations.
So the county health
rankings shows and
provides a diagram
that is very helpful
to see, well, how
much does clinical
care contribute to
health outcomes? So in
this diagram, health
outcome is defined
by length of life
and quality of life.
The areas here are
the health factors
such as health
behaviors, clinical care,
social economic factors,
physical environment.
And it looks like if
you want to have the
greatest and the best
movement of improvement
for health outcomes,
the areas that you
have to affect are
health behaviors, social
economic factors, and
physical environment.
Clinical care is just
20%. It is significant.
There are significant
issues that happen
in a clinical setting
that you will learn
how to avoid and
advocate for patients'
health through these
presentations and the
rest of your education.
But it's also important
to know as an
osteopathic physician,
because we know that if
you approach something,
understanding that
you have to look at
the systems also outside
the human body, where
they live, learn,
work, play, and pray.
If you're aware of those
things, you will be
a better osteopathic
physician, because as
you're taking those
things into consideration,
you'll be able to
customize the appropriate
care for the patient
that is before you.
one of the greatest
misconception in
uh disparities
when they're being
observed is that race
is a biological factor
and nothing can be
further than the truth
it is actually the
act of discrimination
because of race or
any other and a
reason against people
that's a significant
driver of health
disparities and a clear
example of this is in
the practice and
the legalization of
redlining redlining was
a federally supported
discriminate
discriminatory law that
prohibited the granting
of loans to black
individuals and families
which kept black
people and families
from owning properties
forcing them to live
in designated areas.
These areas have
generationally have
been disinvested so
that economic mobility
and stability is
almost non-existent.
Education, options
for healthy foods,
healthy spaces are not
equitable in areas that
were invested where
people could get
loans and buy property.
And these were and
are the major drivers
of health outcomes.
The maps that
you see before
you are maps
of Minneapolis.
The one on the
left are the areas
that have been
redlined. They have the
highest concentration
of people of
color between 1930s
and 1970 by way
of discriminatory
law and practices.
The map on your
right shows the areas
of high infant
mortality in the same
Minneapolis area
between 2001 and 2010.
these areas are the
same areas that were
redlined the areas that
were redlined are the
areas where you have the
highest concentration
of infant mortality
this is an example
of structural racism
while there aren't any
anti-discrimination
laws or or or blatant
discrimination laws to
date The vestiges of
legalized discrimination
are lived experiences
for people today
because of these laws.
The environmental
factors and determinants
of health caused
by redlining are
causing high rate
of infant mortality.
So it's important to
note that you have
to look at the history
of the conditions
of where people
live. That affects
the options and
opportunities of health
that are driving
the health outcomes.
Dr. Williams
published an article
on racism and
health in the Annual
Review of Public
Health in 2019.
It is a significant
publication that I
encourage you to review
to better understand
how the patterns of
racial, ethnic inequities
in health exist,
and we also need to
learn more about it
because we see that
there are rates of
disease and death that
are elevated for
historically marginalized
racial groups such as
black native americans
native hawaiians and
pacific islanders
and if you were
to adjust for
socioeconomic
status which
means if you were
to look at the
people groups who
have the same salary
or socioeconomic status
you still will see
a disparity amongst
ethnic and racial
groups which shows
that it's more than
the amount of money
one may have in their
bank account or their
financial assets.
Research indicates
that across virtually
every type of
diagnostic and treatment
intervention,
****** and other
minorities receive fewer
procedures and poor
quality medical
care than ****** do.
So there is a
significant issue that is
going on in a
healthcare system that
is really important
for you as a rising
osteopathic physician
to be aware of.
another population is
the lgbtq population
um significant
groups uh significant
groups are um within
the lgbt groups
are delaying health
care because of concern
and fear of
discrimination um over
50 percent of lgbtq
plus people report
some form of health
care discrimination
18 percent of lgbt youth
report experiencing
dating violence one out
of five of transgender
people are refused
health care services
there's also financial
health disparities
in providing getting
health health care
services that is much
higher within lgbtq lgbtq
plus groups So it's
important to be aware,
again, of the lack of
access that is causing
health disparities,
but also discriminatory
practices that are
being experienced by
different demographics
within the health care
system that's affecting
health outcomes.
why we might see these
health disparities
specifically in lgbt
groups is that um there's
additional stress
for marginalized
persons who experience
discrimination or stigma
there's lack of access
to adequate health
care services due to
bias or discrimination
in the system policy
or provider level.
Inadequate
public knowledge,
attitudes, and systems.
And health promotion
messages tailored
to LGBT communities
fail to realize
that ****** orientation
identification
is not the same as
****** behavior. And
so there's a lot of
education that needs
to be done in this
area to make sure
people have the
care that they need.
Unequal Treatment,
Confronting
Racial and Ethnic
Disparities
in Health Care
was a landmark
publication by
the Institute
of Medicine,
now known as the
National Institute
of Medicine,
excuse me, the
National Academies of
Sciences. This
landmark study called
Unequal Treatment
really showed through
a panel of experts
who documented
evidence and explored
how persons of color
experience healthcare
environment.
This book examines
how disparities in
treatments may arise in
healthcare systems and
looks at aspects of
the clinical encounter
that may contribute to
such disparities. um
patients and providers
attitudes expectations
and behaviors were
analyzed the um document
also talked about
ways we could improve
um these uh disparities
that individuals
were experiencing
there would be
improvements needed in
medical care financing
allocation of care
availability of
language translation
for those who do
not have English as
a primary language,
community-based care,
and other arenas.
The committee highlights
the potential of
cross-cultural
education to improve
provider-patient
communication and offers
detailed look of how
to integrate cross
-cultural learning within
health professions.
But what has happened
since this
landmark report?
Well, there was a
presentation done
by, presented by
Dr. Brian Smeadley
from the Urban
Institute. He gave a
presentation at the
National Academies
of Science in
February of 2023.
and essentially
provided a perspective
that needed to be
noted, which was, well,
the disparities have
not been narrowed from
the difference of the
year 2000 to 2021.
The Agency for Healthcare
Research Quality
published a report
and saw that for
African, for American
Indian, Alaska Native
populations, the
disparity was reduced only
by 8%. For Asian
populations, 2%. Black
populations, 3%.
Hispanic populations,
4%. Native Hawaiian
Pacific Islanders, 10%.
So we still are seeing
these disparities.
And again, please
keep in mind that we
are still learning
about how the pandemic
it has affected
these health
disparities and
outcomes as well.
Dr. Smedley goes on
to point out, well,
what are the factors
that are associated
with healthcare
inequity? And one thing
that was noted is that
there are separate
and inequitable
healthcare systems due
to residential
segregation, like we talked
about before we saw
in redlining. You
have disinvested
communities where hospitals,
communities aren't
investing, having
good hospitals in
their area. There's a
maldistribution of
healthcare resources,
health systems, limited
provider networks.
There's also a tiered
health insurance
and differences in
provider reimbursement.
And this really does
drive the type of
care that individuals
receive. There's
clinician biases,
stereotypes, and prejudices,
race-based clinical
decision support,
and algorithms, and
a persistent lack of
diversity among
healthcare professionals.
Dr.
Gengopadahaya also
noted that there was a
medical apartheid as
there were inequitable
care for patients
of color. The study
investigated the differences
between black and
white patient safety
measures and using
hospital discharge
records from 27 states.
And in that study,
they saw that
black patients
experience a higher
rate of adverse
patient safety events
on 55% of patient
safety measures.
For 82% of patient
safety indicators, black
patients were significantly
less likely to
be admitted to hospitals
that were classified
as high quality.
And high quality was
defined as the hospitals
that were best at
minimizing patient
safety risk based on the
median of value of a
value of each patient
safety indicator this
same research team found
black patients experience
higher rates of
hospital acquired illnesses
or injuries related
to surgical procedures
relative to white
patients treated in
the very same hospital
within hospital
differences black and
white adverse patient
safety rates remain
when comparing black
and white patients
with similar coverage
types so this
study really just
showed that even within
the same hospital
you have different
populations of groups
specifically here
in racial
groups where the
health care is
not equitable
dr smeedly also noted
and this was adapted
from his presentation
that out of a
systematic review of
15 studies that there
were implicit biases
and health outcomes
confirmed among
healthcare professionals
um against black
latinx dark-skinned
individuals as the
general population
and that implicit
bias was significantly
related to patient
provider interactions
treatment decisions
treatment adherence
patient health outcomes
there was also a
systematic review of 37
studies that confirmed
substantial evidence
of pro-white or light
-skinned anti-black
hispanic american
indian or dark-skinned
biases among a variety
of healthcare professionals
across multiple
levels of training
and disciplines it
was also these these
disparities were also
noted within the
electronic health record
researchers analyzed
a sample of 40 000
history and physical
notes. And you're
going to be learning
how to take soap notes
in the coming months.
But I just wanted
you to be aware of
studies of soap notes
or documentations of
patient encounters.
In this sample size,
they found that 18,000
patients approximately
had sentences containing
negative descriptors,
such as resistant,
non-compliant of
the patient or the
patient's behavior they
sought to determine the
odds of finding at
least one negative
descriptor as a function
of the patient's race
and ethnicity um
controlling force and the
control for socio
-demographic and health
characteristics um when
compared with white people
black patients had
two and a half times
the odds of having
at least one negative
descriptor in the history
and physical notes.
Their findings raise
concerns that there was
stigmatizing language
in the electronic
health records, and it
potentially exacerbates
racial and ethnic
health care disparities.
What is being noted
in this presentation
are studies and
publications that are
bringing light to
a reality of lived
experiences of people
who live in the United
States. You, as an
osteopathic physician
to be, have the
opportunity to be the
difference, to advocate
and to save lives.
This is the current
reality. There are
tensions and challenges
that healthcare
system presents that
are compounding with
many other issues that
may bring barriers
to really provide
good care for people.
The next part of this
presentation will
show you how to
be the difference,
how to advocate, and
how to save lives.
Hello, this is Dr.
Brooke Shield Laurent,
osteopathic family
medicine physician,
associate professor
and chairwoman for
the Department of
Clinical Medicine
at NYIT College
of Osteopathic
Medicine at Arkansas
State University.
I also serve as the
executive director
for the Delta Population
Health Institute,
the community engagement
arm for NYTCOM.
This presentation is
in the second part
of our discussion of
health disparities,
Closing the Gap Through
Cultural Competencies.
In the second segment
of this presentation,
we will be
defining, at the end
of this presentation,
you should be
able to define
and explain the
frameworks of
cultural competency.
Explain the
role of cultural
beliefs in
influencing health.
Explain the role of
cultural competence
and humility in
addressing the
disparity gaps in
healthcare. care.
Before we take
a deep dive into
cultural competency,
let's take a
moment to define
what is culture.
Culture is considered
a central concept in
the study of anthropology
and sociology.
It encompasses a range
of phenomenas that
are transmitted
through social learning
in human societies
it reflects the
whole of human behavior
including ideas
attitudes ways to
relate to one another
manners of speaking
or expression systems
of belief etiquette law
morals entertainment
and education
that are commonly
shared among members
of a particular group
Something to keep in mind
is that any individual
can identify with
one or more culture.
Also something to keep
in mind is that culture
is not necessarily
synonymous with race.
So what is cultural
competency?
Well, first,
let's start with
what is not
cultural competency.
Cultural competency
is not being really
polite, although you
should be. but even
a very polite and
well-mannered, well
-intended individual
may lack cultural
competency. So just
something to keep in
mind is that we're
not equating manners
and politeness to
cultural competencies.
Also, cultural
competency is not just
because, not just about
being able to speak a
person's language that
connection actually
can help but even
if you do speak the
language or understand
the language of another
group of people does
not necessarily mean
that the individual
or you may have
competencies related to
cultural competencies
another thing that
culture competency
isn't is um it isn't
about knowing the
stereotypes of different
cultures um there
is a strong temptation
to put a broad
brushstroke of
different people groups
it's something that's
done very often
and even within our
own western culture,
things that we may
hear or experience.
But it's very important
not to come in
resting and relying
or depending on these
learned stereotypes
of different cultures.
This can be hazardous,
certainly if
misappropriated, and also
does not show a posture
of someone who's learning
and understanding
that not everyone
in a specific people
group adhere to all
of the norms within
that people group. So
it's one, it's very
important. These are
common things that I
often come up with. This
is not an exhaustive
list when we talk
about cultural
competency, but these
are things certainly to
keep, some of the
things to keep in mind.
The definition of
cultural competency will
be adopting from the
NIH and essentially
cultural competency
positively impacts care
through service delivery
that is respectful
of and responsive
to the health belief
practices cultural
and linguistic
needs of diverse patients
it's understanding
it's adapting
and being responsive
to individuals
from other cultures
with different
belief systems
than your own.
The ability of
health professionals
to communicate and
effectively provide
high-quality care
to patients from
diverse sociocultural
backgrounds.
In this discipline of
cultural competency,
there have been
some emerging terms.
A term called cultural
competability.
um what this term
aims to do is to
reconcile the relationship
between cultural
competency and
cultural humility and
here's why in this
discipline of cultural
competency there's
been a critique that
this term cultural
competency can be seen
as acquiring a technical
skill, something
that is to be
mastered. And there
is a strong potential
of reinforcing and
adhering to
stereotypes, and that it
really does not
genuinely address the
issues and underlying
issues of inequities
or social justice.
So those are
some of the critiques
in the discipline.
Uh, cultural humility
has been, um,
uh, a word, a
term that's been
used that talks
about, um,
uh, dynamic
and a lifelong
process of focusing
on self-reflection
and personal
critique, uh,
in the area of
learning and, and, um,
understanding others.
So while we may not use
cultural competability
throughout this
entire presentation,
I just wanted you
to be aware of
some of these
emerging terms as
you may be desiring
to learn more
and go deeper into
the literature.
You may see these
terms. For the sake
of this presentation,
we'll be using
the word cultural
competency, but
being aware of
these contingencies,
that this is not something
that is necessarily
mastered because we
can never understand
and learn all of
the cultures in the
globe, but it really
is a posture of, um,
and of, of continual
lifelong commitment
to understanding the
lived experiences
of people that requires
self-reflection
and personal critique
and so i just wanted
to make this these
definitions um clearer
to you and even
just hold attention
for some of these
definitions because this
is a very dynamic
topic and discussion
this is a venn diagram
of the process of
cultural competency
and i like the word
process of cultural
competency, because
indeed it is. It's a
lifelong commitment, as
I noted before. This
process of cultural
competency requires
cultural awareness,
cultural knowledge,
cultural skill,
cultural encounters,
and cultural desire.
And these five elements
overlapping one
another is the
place where you'll
see a process, the
process of cultural
competency.
In the area of cultural
awareness, one of
the areas of the Venn
diagram, it's the place
of self-examination.
It's in-depth exploration
of your own cultural
and professional
background, recognition
of your own biases,
assumptions, or
prejudices. So the more
you, um, have in a
greater awareness of
yourself, um, awareness
of what you carry into
a conversation with
people or different
types of people, the
more you are engaging
in this process of
cultural competency.
The next area that
was in that Venn
diagram was cultural
knowledge. And
that's the process of
seeking and obtaining
sound educational
foundation about
diverse cultural
and ethnic groups.
Intracultural
variation is the
avoiding of stereotypes
and understanding
that everyone in
a culture adhere
to various degrees
of the culture.
So it's always important
to keep in mind
that when you're
having any inquiries,
that is important
specifically to the medical
care of the patient
you'll be caring
for is that it's
important just to ask and
to explain why you're
asking questions
pertaining to their
culture that may have
an impact on their
health outcome to get
a better understanding
of what degree does
this individual adhere
to their culture
the next area
in that previous
venn diagram was
cultural knowledge
The clinician must
be able to integrate
health-related beliefs
and cultural values in
the care of the patient,
understanding what
is important, what is
the driving why for
the patient, what are
the perspectives and
worldviews that influence
the behavior, the
health, and the
understanding of the patient
is vital, regardless
of how well a physician
is able to manage
high blood pressure, a
heart attack, a ******,
or any other chronic
or acute illness. But
if they're able to
inquire thoughtfully,
respectfully, the
understanding of what
is important in terms of
values of the patient,
it will allow you to
provide a customized
care for this patient.
The clinician must
be able to integrate
disease incidence
and prevalence.
So essentially,
being aware of
prevalence of
illness in people
groups actually
is helpful,
not assuming that all
people may have an
illness, but to have
an awareness that there
is a prevalence. For
instance, in the previous
presentation, we talked
about the maternal
and infant health,
particularly in
minority population.
And because we are aware
of that data, there's
a certain level of
awareness that we bring
into these encounters
so that we can be
present a certain level
of thoughtfulness when
we're providing care.
And also the efficacy
of treatment is
important. If you're
not aware about how the
culture of an individual
responds to how um,
the culture of an
individual, um,
um, sees the
treatment that you're
offering, it may not be
effective. It may
not be effective.
The other area in
that Venn diagram was
cultural, cultural skill.
And essentially that's
the ability to collect
relevant cultural
data regarding the patient's
presenting problem,
as well as accurately
performing physical
assessment in cultural
contexts in mind. So
the collection of
cultural data, as you're
learning more about
your patient, if it is
certainly relevant to
the care of your patient,
if they're telling
you where their family
is from, what are the
meals that they eat,
what are the activities
they participate in.
Those things can be
really helpful to
understand the context
of the mind of your
patient, right? Who's
important in their family
unit that they must
include in their care.
Not everyone that
you're going to see may
have a Western mindset
in the way that, um,
and Western mindset
in the way that we
think about healthcare.
Perhaps you're engaging
with an individual
where the family
unit is considered in
decision making. And
so there are ways
that you have to learn
how to navigate that
perspective to provide
care, not only for
that individual, but
because that individual
invites other family
members, how to
help to have them
participate in those
decision making as well.
Also in the process,
again, the process of
cultural competency are
cultural encounters.
You must encounter
with people who are not
like you. You must
engage. You will engage
with people who are not
like you, most likely.
But if you find yourself
that you're not,
putting yourself in that
position will actually
help you in your
lifelong commitment to
do so. This process
encourages healthcare
professionals to
directly engage in cross
-cultural interactions with
patients with different
backgrounds, and
even cross-cultural
interactions with your
team members as well in
the healthcare team
cultural encounters will
also require assessment
of linguistic needs
whether it has to do
with someone who may
be may not be proficient
in the english
language or they may be
deaf or hard of hearing
so you have to understand
or learn how you
can meet that specific
need to communicate.
And one key point
here is having really
the motivation to
want to, rather than
I have to engage
with a process in the
process of being
culturally aware, right?
How you approach
this whole dynamic is
so key. The level
of motivation that
you have to desire
and want to do it is
really important and
really sets the stage
for the success of
these encounters.
Here's a guide
to assess how to
develop consistent
cultural humility.
So one, ask questions
in a humble manner.
This is what a lifelong
learner is committed
to do. But one of the
things you have to
keep in mind when
you ask questions is
that you're not asking
questions for the sake
of your curiosity,
right? But you should
only really be asking
questions because it
sincerely and truly
has a lot to do with
the medical issue or
care of the patient.
And you should always
explain to the patient
why you're asking
that question, right?
Why are you asking
them about their
background? Why
is that important
to the care that
you provide?
how that informs
the customized care
that you provide for
them. So if you're
able to transition and
ask them and explain
why you're asking
them in a humble
manner, it's actually
quite inviting and
comforting that a
physician would take
the time to want
to know a place of
origin. How were they,
how did they experience
their life, their
life as a child?
What difficulties or
joys they experienced
growing up? What
did they learn about
health? What was
their experience with
healthcare professionals
growing up in that
context? Those types
of questions are really
important and it
informs you how this
individual is approaching
you, how this individual
is engaging with the
healthcare system.
Next is seek self
-awareness and you're
going to have to have
some honest people
around you who will
hold you accountable,
right? So we can't
just, we won't see what
we see until there's
someone else holding
a mirror for us. So
seek self-awareness.
One, also suspend
judgment. We all judge.
Judgment is going to
happen. We're human
beings. In healthcare,
when someone comes
with a complaint,
we have immediately,
once you get used
to it, you'll make
judgments about what
it could be, what it
may not be, what it
might be, what it
definitely isn't, et
cetera, X, Y, and Z.
So we do judge, but
the issue here is that
you're asked to
suspend your judgment.
And what that
means is you might
have a judgment
that comes to mind.
Just pause, let it
sit on the shelf
and you might
have to test your
assumptions, right?
In a respectful way.
So just don't jump
to conclusions.
Just, okay, a judgment
comes to mind.
put a pin on it. Be
aware of it. Hold
that tension there.
Be aware that
without checking
that judgment, it can
influence how you
speak to the patient,
how you care to
with the patient.
So again, suspend
your judgment.
Okay. The next
is E, express
kindness and
compassion. Always,
always. You can't,
you can't lose with
this. Express kindness
and compassion.
as support a safe and
welcoming environment.
And this is done through
verbal and
nonverbal skills.
A welcoming environment
doesn't just start
with, hey, welcome
to my clinic. Maybe
there's something in
your intake form that
makes them feel
unwelcome, that makes them
feel other than, that
makes them feel unseen.
Maybe there's signs
around you or the
area makes them feel
like they really don't
belong and you have
to get assessments of
those spaces. So a
welcoming environment
is more than a welcome
sign. It's the sense
that people feel that
they belong in your
space where you're
providing care. Okay.
And the last S is start
where the patient
is, right?
Begin where the
patient is. That
requires inquiry,
that requires empathy,
that requires
understanding. So
culture and health.
Culture is a
significant, a
significant issue
in health care.
And we may not learn
about every culture,
but you should
understand how culture
affects communication
and health outcomes.
When there is a lack of
cultural competencies,
there's a there's
some impacts to
clinical outcomes you
should be aware of.
It leads to barriers
that may include,
but are not limited
to, stigmas,
mistrust of the
patient in healthcare,
the healthcare
system and healthcare
professionals,
discrimination,
poor health outcomes
as we talked
about before,
but also higher
costs in
healthcare itself.
There are studies
that have shown this.
Other impact of
clinical outcomes
that patients
fear of being
misunderstood
or disrespected.
Providers not
familiar with the
prevalence of
conditions among certain
minority groups, if
you're not aware of
that, that has
significant outcomes.
Healthcare professionals
may fail to take
into account
differing responses to
medications or may lack
knowledge about the
traditional remedies
leading to harmful drug
interactions if they
don't ask about it.
Patients may not adhere
to medical advice
because they don't
understand or trust
the provider. That
can happen when
there's a lack of
cultural competencies.
There can be more or
fewer diagnostic tests
for patients of
different cultural
backgrounds, And that
really can affect finding
the illness or if
it's underdiagnosed,
missed illnesses.
If there are four
broad categories
of how culture
influences health,
it would be in
the following.
Cultures affect
health care seeking
behavior. okay um we
are informed by our
culture how we've
been raised um the
area of the globe
we've been raised and
how and when and
the way that we seek
health care um is
influenced by that
how we perceive the
causes of our illnesses
is is informed by our
culture understanding
of disease processes
how and why illnesses
are developing in our
bodies are informed by
our culture and
treatment decisions why I
choose one thing over
the other is driven by
our culture what I have
presented to you is
the dimensions of the
health believe model
model the dimensions
include perceived
susceptibility which
means an individual's
perceptions
of their chances of
getting the disease
perceived seriousness an
individual's knowledge
related to the
severity of the disease
perceived benefits an
individual's opinion
of desirable behavioral
health beliefs
that need to be taken
into consideration
during the treatment
plans, perceived
barriers and individuals'
opinions as to what
will stop them from
seeking behavioral
health services or health
services in general
and returning for
continued services.
And then the last
dimension is self
-efficacy. And that's
the individual's belief
that they can do
something to improve
their current
situation. Now, it's
important to be aware
of these dimensions
because as you're
educating a patient, if
they don't perceive
that it is serious,
they may not take
your advice to heart.
If they're not
convinced that
there's any benefit,
your recommendations
may not be
adhered to. Um,
a culture or a
lack of trust, um,
um, a culture of, of
the value of health
or how value is, how
health is perceived
or the trust they may
have in the healthcare
professional may
affect their, their,
their thoughts of
why the benefits of
health, the benefits,
uh, are perceived.
The culture also informs
the barriers, right?
So what is keeping
this individual from
getting health care?
Now, this model that I'm
showing you was based
out of the Technical
Assistance Network for
Children's Behavioral
Health, but you can
replace that for health
in general. So what
are the things or
thoughts and opinions,
for example, in the topic
of mental health, if
the culture stigmatizes
health and finds
mental health and sees
mental health simply
as a spiritual thing,
that may keep that
individual from seeking
medical treatment
for the mental
health disease that
they're experiencing.
So it's important
to know what this
individual's perceived
susceptibility is,
how serious it is,
what the benefits
barriers and how they
can engage through
empowerment in their
own care. These are
very valuable concepts
to keep in mind.
And again, in the
context of behavioral
health, and this
really can be
used for other health
values, not just
behavioral health
issue questions.
The graphs that I have
in the next couple
of slides actually
breaks down some
questions that can
be asked around
susceptibility and perceived
seriousness, right?
So around perceived
susceptibility,
one question is, does
anyone among your
friends and your
family share the same
issue as you? Did they
seek help? What was
the result? Just
seeing how people, um,
engage with, uh, health,
um,
engage with, um,
um, the healthcare
system, asking them
what role do your
spiritual belief play
in, uh, in regaining
your health? Those
are really important
questions to ask.
Perceive seriousness,
right? What do you
know about your current
issue that brought you
here today? Some
questions you may ask.
how do people in your
community talk about
mental illness as an
example or it could be
anything else such as
heart attack or ******
health right how different
is the perception
of your health issue
in the american
culture compared to the
culture of your country
of origin if their
country of the origin
is the united states
so these are just
questions that you can
use not every single one
of these questions
but certainly some
questions to get a better
understanding of how
this person perceives
the seriousness of their
illness because that
way you can intervene
based on where they're
at meeting them
where they are perceived
benefits one question
you might ask is
um what things are
meaningful in your
life right what role do
spiritual beliefs play
in regaining your health
do you meditate
um have you had
any position ex
positive experiences
with behavioral uh health
Under perceived barriers,
have you ever been
discriminated against
for being different?
How did you react?
How do you want your
behavioral health care
specialist to treat
you? So these questions
are refreshing, and
these are not common
questions. If you've
been to the health
care, I've seen a health
care professional,
there's not common
things that you
hear, but I ask
you as osteopathic
physicians to start
having a repertoire of
questions that
really will show the
patient that you
really care about their
well-being and
want to learn more.
So take a time, go
through these questions,
have a few of them
in your pocket,
just so that you
can get a better
understanding of where
your patient is at.
So keep in mind,
cultural forces are very
powerful and they
affect health behaviors.
And if you're not
aware of it and
you're not sensitive
to it, it will limit
your ability to take
good care of folks.
I want to share
with you a patient.
This was a patient
that I, um, uh,
that I patient that
I, um, cared for
when I first came
out of residency.
Um, and I just wanted
to kind of just
share with you an
experience I had in
this, this, Um, her
name is, is, um,
um,
I used a different
name here to
protect, protect
her, her identity.
Um, but for the most
part, this is the
general gist and
the experience, um,
that, that we
had. So I saw a
33 year old woman
from Pakistan.
Um, she's a Muslim
woman and she presented
to the clinic for
an evaluation.
And in her official
screening, she noted
that English is
her second language
and she's she's
proficient in English.
So she did not require
an interpreter.
She was very comfortable
communicating with me.
She also shared that
she had preferred to
see female, a female
physician. And in the
encounter, I came to
find out that she had
a medical history of
diabetes and she hadn't
been taking her
medications for some time
now. i'm just trying
to get a better
understanding of um
why um and get a better
understanding of what
happened and something to
the point of she just
wanted to get back
on it again she hasn't
been feeling well um
and so it's just a
discussion that we had
during that time but
what really drove her
to come in was because
she had complaints
of vaginal discharge
and frequency
and urination So
we did some labs.
We found out that
her blood sugars
indeed was very
much elevated.
And in that, we realized
we needed to start
her back on her
medication. She was on
insulin. We gave her
and provided in-depth
education, had her repeat
back the instructions.
She said she was
committed to get
back on it and she was
supposed to come back
and see me after
after a month with her
results with her with
her records so we can
go ahead and and um
and make sure that she
was right on track
so upon her return we
rechecked her blood
sugars and it was it
stayed really hot
there wasn't any change
and she still remained
pretty frustrated that
the vaginal discharge
had not resolved.
So what I wanted to
do, because I thought
we educated well,
gave her the right
prescription. She
showed me how she knew
how to take the
insulin and when to
take it and how much
she showed it all. But
I ran into something
and I couldn't,
I had to take a deeper
dive. And I used
the health belief
model to help me, um,
um, get a better
understanding of what's
going on. So when I wanted
to see her perceived
seriousness of this
situation, and it was
the discomfort she
was experiencing, um,
with dysuria and vaginal
discharge. Um, also
her perceived, the
perceived benefits of
treatment I asked her
was that she would be
able to care for her
family. And she was
concerned about the
complications of diabetes.
So it was important
for me to see what
was important for her.
So I could keep that
in mind, um, as a source
of her motivation.
Um, and then I asked
about some barriers.
And when I took a deeper
dive, she said she
felt some shame in using
the insulin, right?
She, um, and she
couldn't eat what, what
her family eats. Like
she couldn't eat what
she cooked for her
family. And that really
brought some sense
of isolation to her.
And so that actually
opened up a lot of
doors and discussion
and really helped me
to see her lived
experience when it came to
diabetes. Diabetes
meant shame for her.
It means isolation.
And usually when we
think about those
illnesses, we really don't
think about it in
that terms, but that
was her lived
experience. And that was
important for me to
keep in mind as I was
coaching and helping
her and supporting her.
The other thing around
self-efficacy is
wanting to know if she
can do it on her own or
if she needed more
professional help, right?
And how can we use
the role of her family
and her spirituality to
enable self-efficacy?
So just so that you
know, little bit
background, the elevated
blood sugars cause
increased urination. So
that's why she was having
these issues. So the
blood sugars itself
being high was not
alarming, but this part
was in the vaginal
discharge, which was a
yeast infection that
causes us, that usually
comes from uncontrolled
blood sugars of
what really was driving
it. So that's what
caused her. So if she
had, you know, checked
her blood and her
blood sugars are really
high, that wasn't the
thing that tipped her
off the edge. It were
these complications
from it that was, that
was causing it. So,
um, I just wanted
to just share with
you just the
breakdown of how this
model can give me
a better insight of
how she was
experiencing diabetes.
As I mentioned before,
culture influences
how people make
judgment and make sense
about the world and
the decisions about
their behavior. um it
defines good it defines
bad healthy unhealthy
large body types
in some cultures may
signify wealth and
well-being right um it
affects daily habits
of living food choices
for people groups
who live in the
mediterranean is much
different from people
who um live in the
united states so just
really important again
not to overlook culture
these are just a
few graphs that
highlight how behaviors,
culture-related
behaviors affect health.
For example,
cultures can affect
how food are prepared.
Cultures can affect,
cultures related
to the type of
interventions that
are acceptable.
Cultures related to
the response of disease
and interventions,
right? And how they
adhere to the
practices or adhere to
the recommendations
that one may make.
Okay, so just some
things to keep in mind.
Religion also,
there's a culture
within different
religions and
that may affect
****** behaviors,
certain food to avoid
or some religions
that doesn't allow
the eating of certain
foods like pork or beef
or drinking alcohol
or tobacco use. So
those are important
things to keep in mind
in terms of how culture
may inform health
behavior. So as I
mentioned before, religion
may influence attitudes
and social practices,
****** practices,
food, alcohol,
tobacco, response to
symptoms. People groups
may not prescribe
traditional Western
medical care as a response
to symptoms. Some
people may choose to
respond by first through
prayer and meditation
before they go and
seek out health
care. And so that's
important to know that.
So you can incorporate
that or be aware
of that in the care
you're providing
patients. Other areas
where you might see
religion, faith
or spirituality
influencing health is
types of intervention,
right? Blood
transfusion for Jehovah
Witnesses, attitudes
towards stem cell
research, attitude
towards contraception
or abortion,
certain aspects of
end-of-life treatment,
even fertility,
response to diseases,
the role of prayer
as an intervention
to alter outcomes. So
these are lived
experiences that you should
be aware of. And
having a patient know
that their physician,
even if you don't
practice or share
that, but the fact that
you're bringing it up
in the conversation
really will show that
patient that you care
and that they want to
share more information
with you. And that
information they
share with you really
can unlock some
things for you in the
way that you provide
care. So really important
to keep in mind.
Again, I've mentioned
this before that
while we talk about
culture, there are
various degrees to
which individuals adhere
to the norms of
their own culture. So
don't assume they
adhere to all the norms.
Let them let you know
to ask them first,
right? Because it's
important for you to know
because it is affecting
their health care.
and keep in mind
that people belong
to more than one
culture, okay?
Culture related to
gender identity or
geography or profession,
right? Being a
healthcare professional
is a culture.
We have our own
language, the way we
process things, the
way we engage with
the world and other
people. So we live
in subcultures within
ourselves as complex
human beings.
there are five
essential elements of
cultural competencies
one assessing cultural
knowledge and avoiding
stereotypes in
the process valuing
diversity managing the
dynamic of difference
right there's a the
way that we manage
that is really key
and adapting to
diversity and then
institutionalizing cultural
knowledge these five
core context concepts
are um are known
as these five essential
elements to
cultural competency.
So when you, when
we're, our approach to
cultural competency is
that we're developing
a skill set and a framework
through a critical
conscious of self and
others in the world.
And we're really
posturing ourselves as a
curious learner. So
in cultural humility,
in this context is
developing a lifelong
commitment towards self
-evaluation and critique,
as I mentioned before,
when engaging with
patients and communities
of different culture,
always from a place
of empathy, right?
And understanding.
Now we say this now,
because right now you're
sitting, you're listening
to this lecture,
you're taking some
notes, but when you are
in the heat of health,
the healthcare system,
where your patient
panel is long, there
are complex situations.
You may be dealing with
your own situations.
You may be dealing
with your own problems
and you're coming
into a very complex
healthcare system with
a complex healthcare
team. Those tensions
are very, very real. And
if you don't learn how
to practice mindfulness,
self-evaluation
and critique in the
most tense times,
because the healthcare
system is not the
easiest place to practice
this. That's why I'm
telling you this now so
you can be aware of
this if you begin to
practice these mindsets
and it becomes like a
second hand for you
no matter what the
tensions are you can
you'll be able to to to
step into this mode of
cultural humility almost
immediately because
you're aware if not
if not if you don't
errors are going
to happen if you
don't cost will
be high if you don't
people can die.
And when you have that
level of awareness,
you will pause, you
will be mindful no
matter how tension
and how high the
tension may be when
you're stepping into
that. So you'll always
have that tension as
a healthcare
professional. You'll see
those things are there.
That's why you have
to start practicing
those skills now.
Okay.
Um, the cultural
proficiency continuum
is a model that's often
used to talk about
cultural competency
as a spectrum, right?
So there's cultural
destructiveness,
cultural incapacity,
cultural blindness,
cultural pre
-competency, cultural
competence, and cultural
proficiency. All right.
So as I mentioned
before, I know that
we have been talking
about different
terms in a discipline
of cultural competency,
cultural humility,
cultural competability.
Okay. This is a
spectrum of, um,
different spaces
people may land in the
continual of cultural
proficiency. Okay.
So the first three
cultural destructiveness,
cultural incapacity,
cultural blindness are
on the negative, uh,
side of the spectrum,
right? So, um, under
cultural destructiveness,
they see, an individual
may see a cultural
difference and they
aim to eliminate it.
Okay.
Um,
a prime example of
this is indigenous
people in this
country, right? So, um,
you have a group
of people from a
different, from a
different place who comes
to this, to this,
to this country, um,
and encounter
indigenous people and
literally indigenous
people were eliminated,
uh, where this culture
would be due to,
um, so many, so many
things that have, um,
essentially genocide
that has eliminated
this people group.
Next you see, see
culture difference and
you devalue it, right?
So, um, yes, there's
a difference, but
it's less than, um,
it's your, you, there's
a posture of
superiority over it. Um,
and that's cultural
incapacity. And there's
cultural blindness,
where you see cultural
difference, but you
act as if it, if
you don't, as if it
doesn't matter, something
where someone
may say, oh, I'm
colorblind, right? I'm
culturally blind. Well,
although the intent
of that comment
is usually said to
explain that, um,
um, that, that there is
no difference amongst
people, that posture
actually is, is, can,
can cause some danger
to people because
if you're not aware
of how someone's lived
experience is affecting
how they engage with
the healthcare system,
you are negating a
whole side of their
lives that needs to be
aware of so that you
can provide really good
care. So it's not a
helpful posture to be
culturally blind. Okay.
On the other side of
the continuum, you
have cultural pre
-competence, right? You
have, you see the cultural
difference and you're
making some efforts,
but it's not working
out that great. It's
maybe not responding
totally appropriately,
but you know, you have
to. So you're kind
of in this learning
stage, you know, you have
to make a difference,
but there's some
response that's, that's
inappropriately made.
And then the next one
is cultural competence.
So you see the
cultural difference,
you appreciate it and
actually making more
appropriate steps,
right? And the next
step after that is
seeking is cultural
proficiency, where
you're actually seeking
out these experiences.
Like you desire it,
you wanna learn more,
you're an advocate
for that inequity. So
that's the spectrum
of cultural competency
or proficiency.
And this is just for the
breakdown of
this definition
adapted from a manual
for school leaders
around the area of
cultural competency, right?
And cultural
destructiveness, as we said
before, you see the
difference you want to
stomp it out so that
could be manifested in
attitudes practices
policies that are
destructive to cultures
you have cultural
incapacity you see the
difference you make it
wrong so there are
systems and individuals in
a culture that are
extremely biased believe
in a superiority of
a dominant group and
assume paternal posture
toward those of the
lesser groups and these
systems or individuals
are often characterized
by unrealistic
fear of people who
are different from
the dominant group
and then you have
cultural blindness as
we said before, where
the belief that the
culture makes no
difference, right?
There's a belief that
no matter what the
culture of the person,
I'm going to treat
everyone the same.
While you should be
respectful of everyone,
it could be very
dangerous if you make the
same assumptions about
people's lived experiences,
because people's
lived experiences are
different. And that
means how they come into
the healthcare system
and their expectations
will be different,
and those needs will
not be met. So that is
not a helpful posture.
But moving toward pre
-competence is that
there's an awareness,
but there's a
limitation in the way
that you're responding.
Although you want
to desire, you
desire for the change,
moving to competency,
where you begin
to grow and learn,
seek experiences out,
start adapting policies
and practices that
can respond to different
cultural contexts
in the populations
you're caring for.
And then you move to
cultural proficiency
and you see the
difference in response.
So please have these
definite, be comfortable
with these definitions
and these different
milestones in the,
in the continuum.
Moving to our cultural
competency. So elicit
the patient's understanding
of the illness
and strategies for
identifying different
styles of communication.
Ask them, tell me
what you understand
about what's going on,
right? Ask them about
their preferences.
What is the role
of their family
members in their
decision-making,
right?
Acknowledge the use
of complementary
alternative medicine.
If they're using
it, let them ask
them, Hey, tell me
what you're using.
And you're not going
to know every, I
mean, it's such, it's,
there's so many
things out there and
you're not going
to know everything.
Um, but it's really
important to ask, have
a conversation and
say, hey, I'm not
familiar with this over
-the-counter medication
or this thing you're
getting by mail. I'll
have to look some
things up because I want
to know how this may
affect the care that
I'm going to be
providing for you. So I
need to know that.
Perhaps you can hold off
on taking that until
I find out because
I'm giving you some
medication, for example,
for your blood
pressure. I want to make
sure what I'm providing
for you isn't going
to cause a conflict
in your body. Okay.
Being a really good
physician requires some
good negotiation
skills in the best way.
Number one, when you
start with negotiations,
you have that
patient's interest in
mind. That is your
starting point, empathy and
their best interest
in mind. Number two,
their best, your
idea of their best
interest doesn't mean
anything if it's not
centered at the core
of their values,
at the core of their
understanding of their
lived experience, right?
So that must drive
that conversation
when you're providing
care for patients. So,
and there's a lot of
negotiation, right,
about what's important
to them and what you're
providing for them
as a healthcare
professional to see, well,
how does what I'm, how
is what I'm offering
you going to fit in,
in what's important
to you and how you
want to take it, right?
use skills to increase
your awareness of
mistrust prejudice and
the impact that may
have in clinical
decision making so you
must understand your
patient population you
must understand acceptable
social behaviors
you must understand
the awareness of
cultural health and
acquiring cultural
sensitivity and
incorporating all above all
of the above for the
care of your patient
Now, for your DPR
lab, I'm going to ask
you to take the implicit
assessment tests.
There's a hyperlink
on your PowerPoint.
Please take it
before your lab.
Also, in the CPG,
there is a module
that you are going
to be asked to
take on maternal
health and health
disparities. That
module is going to be
needed for you to,
uh, to take, um,
uh, so that it can count
towards your credit
of your truck, towards
credit, towards
your, your, your, your,
um, grade for DPR.
So please make sure that
you take the modules,
read the CPG and take the
IAT before your next lab.
Thank you so much.